[Music]
all right well welcome everyone to the
155 showing of ant-man and the wasp we
should so thanks for coming out to that
metrion here so this is a proactively
restocking inventory using machine
learning my name is Sandeep Parikh I am
part of the Google Cloud solutions
architecture team and so with that why
don't we get started so what we're gonna
cover today first I want to walk through
kind of a basic challenge that we see
often in in retail and inventory and
keeping that stock out and I want to
walk through a few of the kind of modern
approaches that people tend to take when
trying to you know solve inventory
challenges and then we'll figure out how
we can build a system to solve for this
problem all right what are some of the
components we can use to address sort of
the inventory scenario and we'll kind of
map that back to the components inside a
Google cloud platform and what though
what an architecture might look like in
production and I'm hoping to showcase a
little bit of a demo as well before we
get to the end and then finally I want
to close on questions and just so you
know there are mics at the ends of both
of the third or fourth aisle here if not
if you can't get out there just try to
shout and I'll repeat it so that others
can hear it as well
so what's the problem we're trying to
solve in this example right it's produce
bananas in particular so specifically
what we're trying to do is keep bananas
in stock on the floor all right on a
grocery store floor you can imagine a
produce section inside of a larger store
we're trying to keep that in stock now
we can't leave too many out on the floor
because you know obviously they'll go
bad but if we wait too long to restock
them we'll lose sales right and you also
risk that kind of inventory loss by
leaving it in the back room for too long
as well so this is a pretty high
turnover sort of use case where a lot of
product needs to move off the floor
relatively quickly but we need to
restock it just as fast to make sure
we're not missing out and we want to get
rid of anything right this is a
perishable item and you can sort of map
this to several different use cases but
in particular I think produce is a good
one it's a good fit for you know or a
good stand-in for kind of a low margin
high turnover item
so how do folks typically solve
inventory challenges today and and not
just produce by sort of broadly around
inventory challenges there's typically
three main components in these scenarios
RFID cameras and people and if we unpack
each one of those we kind of figure out
that it's not a perfect fit for this
kind of produce style use case so with
RFID there are typically two main
approaches right you have active
tracking or active scanning and that's
where you've got a handheld scanner and
you're walking up and scanning you know
rough areas of individual items the
second approach is passive scanning and
passive requires you to install antennas
up on the walls or in the ceiling and
then you basically blanketing an area
with scans of RFID and you're waiting
for the responses to come back both of
them have their own challenges and
ultimately the costs don't really line
up again with high turnover sort of low
margin items right you're not gonna put
an RFID tag on every every banana every
a head of lettuce
or every pack of gum that's in there and
it also requires a lot of you know
significant investment in both cases in
terms of the handheld scanners it's a
little bit more manageable right because
you can actually outfit several
individuals and they can spend their
time kind of just roaming around the
space scanning freedoms with passive
tracking you don't need to send people
out but there's a high cost for the
antennas right and the antenna placement
and there's also a high cost to actually
correlate each of the readings and
figure out what's accurate right for
passive tracking the accuracy is a
little bit more difficult right out the
gate so it does require it in digital
additional investment to really get to
the same level of accuracy that you
might get out of a handheld scanner but
like I said ultimately the problem is
that the costs don't match up well now
what about cameras cameras are plentiful
right there if they're pretty
inexpensive relatively speaking
especially compared to something like
RFID out the gate and they have pretty
good resolution and they actually have
kind of a dual purpose right or
multi-purpose
you can use them for security footage as
well as watching stock but there are
some caveats
so with stock
you're probably only gonna get kind of
an overhead view of the world right
you're not gonna get down to sort of
shelf level so it's not a great solution
for every single kind of stock or
inventory use case and again you can
imagine like I'm thinking of like a
grocery store in my head but ultimately
the problem with cameras is that they
require somebody actually evaluating the
footage that's coming off of them you
effectively need someone or something
monitoring them to decide what to do
which brings us to the third kind of
approach and I think one of the harder
challenges as well which is people write
in both cases if you've got you know
active RFID tracking or you've got
cameras deployed you need people there
to actually administer and operate this
mechanism and people are hard to scale
right you've got a higher fair amount of
people to get the to get folks turnover
get enough coverage in terms of holding
the scanners or watching the camera
footage across a number of different
cameras they're also hard to train right
you're not gonna keep training more and
more people but ultimately the biggest
problem is that your end up with a lot
of wasted cycles you end up having a lot
of people who might just sort of be
standing around and you know as much as
I would love to be paid to stare at
produce all day long it's not terribly
exciting so one of the things we can do
is we can make smarter cameras that's a
great way to do this now we have a
camera on the front end and we have a
pretty powerful brain behind it and
that's how we can solve this problem and
really what you get down to is a pretty
simple technology on the front end for
kind of capturing the data that we need
to gather but we still need a scalable
technology behind it to analyze that
footage all right so we kind of laid out
the challenge we've kind of covered a
little bit of the approach now we know
what our challenge is right so let's
figure out what are the pieces we need
to make this work right at a high level
let's talk about the kind of major
pillars here so there's five major
pieces the first air cameras right
that's kind of a solved problem we've
kind of figured out that those are those
are going to be there we also need a
scalable storage mechanism to store the
footage that we're gonna pull off of
those cameras then we need some kind of
a classification mechanism images video
something to put that
brain behind the camera footage and then
we actually have to finish this up and
say how do we notify a store associate
or a team member on the floor and let
them know that they've got to go restock
you know the item that in question and
then the final piece in the middle there
is orchestration how do we get this
whole machine humming and running
operating on a regular basis so the
bottom sort of four components are the
ones that we can do inside a Google
cloud so you can imagine you've got
cameras deployed at the store right
those need to actually push those images
up to a storage the classifier will pick
up those images classify them figure out
what's in them and then based on what
they see they'll send a message out to
the team member so all that we can do in
that orchestration component that runs
at all all of that can run inside a GCP
today so just to quickly recap here
right
cameras are plentiful right they scale
up from consumer class to commercial
class you can find them in all manner of
different resolutions or black and white
or color you can get really cool fisheye
ones ones that are mounted on the
ceiling and pan and zoom there's an
endless array of cameras trust me I
looked before of the talk just to see
what was out there and you actually have
the option of streaming or sampling that
data right the thing to remember here is
that if you imagine a scenario where
you've got hundreds of stores thousands
of stores streaming video off of every
security camera back up to a cloud
infrastructure technically speaking not
terribly difficult but from a bandwidth
and cost perspective again you're
getting into that equation of do the
cost line up with what I'm trying to
solve for so you'd know me you may not
necessarily want to over invest in
network bandwidth so string video when
sampling every minute with a you know a
two megapixel image could be just as
sufficient once you get into the cloud
side of things that's where we need
storage right we need a scalable object
storage platform to store this data
coming in so we would have the kind of
camera upload that that data and you
need a little bit of local device or a
kind of a control plane there's
something that's you know on the store
side to capture and sample the images
package them up and then send them to
cloud infrastructure and that local
device can be anything from you know
I've seen people deploy things
single board computers like a Raspberry
Pi all the way up to like rack mount
servers it really just depends on the
sort of size and scope and the number of
cameras you've got there and effectively
how often you're sampling as well all
right what about a classifier it turns
out building an image classifier is a
non-trivial exercise right you need a
lot of data science expertise and
understanding to train a model and to
build and train a model and then you
need a fair amount of aux sexpert ease
to really deploy and scale that model
right and run it for again a production
use case like this again think of the
model of a lot of cameras across a large
store a lot of team members and now
multiply that by a hundred or a thousand
right that's a lot it's got a process
through and understand so it's gonna
have to be very scalable in production
ready well how can we make this easier
on the Google cloud side that's where
the cloud vision API comes in the vision
API imagine this is a turnkey
pre-trained model all you have to do is
give it images and what it gives back to
you are everything we find in the image
that could be any kind of classified at
any kind of classification any sort of
object detection face detection it can
actually read words as well it does OCR
it has OCR capabilities so anything you
need to sort of pull out of an image
right is possible the vision API
anything you need to learn and it can do
a lot of complicated things like for
example if you have you know sort of two
objects in there it'll tell you the
color it'll tell you the percentage of
those colors as they occur within that
image so you have a lot of capability
here and it's a it's a really easy API
to get started with but what if that's
not enough either right you can imagine
a scenario where well what if you have a
very particular use case or a very
particular setup and you need a little
bit more than just what the stock vision
API gives you for that we actually have
something called Auto ml auto ml is an
effort that started out of the Google AI
team right the research team inside of
Google and their focus was really on you
know building machine learning models
and I didn't expect you be able to read
this text by the way but apparently it's
probably somewhat legible
but their focus was really on saying
look building machine learning models
requires a lot of manual work right how
can we make this process easier well we
know that when you're trying to build
something right instead of even a narrow
use case there's still a lot of I
wouldn't say boilerplate but there are
some known permutations that are person
there that are certainly possible well
what if we could build a neural network
to generate a machine learning model
right and that's what Auto ml is so
we've taken out all Mel and we've
applied it to vision and now what we can
do is you provide labeled image data to
us we can actually build a machine
learning model and give that back to you
and so it's a machine learning mo that's
trained on your image data and it's
customed to you specifically it's not
shared amongst any other projects or any
other customers it's dedicated to just
your use case and what's even better is
the same serving infrastructure that
serves the cloud vision API serves your
auto ml model so that means when you
make your vision API call by default
it'll use the standard model we've built
for you but you actually have an option
there to change to a custom model and
you can just highlight the custom model
in the version you want to use and it'll
actually use your machine learning all
that we generated on your behalf and
what's even better is if you don't have
labeled images that's okay we can
actually help annotate them for you as
well so we have a lot of the capability
that you need again to build something
very specific now what I will often tell
people in the real world is the vision
API might get you the stock vision if
you might get you 60 70 80 percent of
the way and there might be that last 20%
but let's figure out what that is first
so don't invest too much time if you
don't have images quite yet let's try
the vision API as it is and if that's
not a good fit then we can move on to
auto ml so if you look at the breakdown
of usage right in a really simple
scenario here I've got images and I want
to pass them through a classifier that's
very capable right on the bottom I've
got the stock vision API and on the top
I've got the auto vision API and again
the only distinction here is that auto
ml vision needed one additional input
which was a bunch of labeled images
upfront I
that they look feel and function in
exactly the same way alright so what
about the messaging component right how
do we notify an associate or a team
member on the floor that they've got to
go restock well that's where firebase
comes in firebase is our complete sort
of mobile backend as a service and I'm
not going to go through all of what
firebase has but imagine write a system
for authentication you know complete
SDKs for for Android and iOS and it
actually supports web applications as
well gives you real-time database
synchronization behind the scenes so
it's got a whole bunch of functionality
and I've even touched on you know a good
portion of it but a whole mess of
functionality that you can use to build
mobile applications and part of those
one of those key features that we need
to leverage in this case is messaging so
a built in push messaging support and
that's what I'll use here and actually
that push messaging also supports the
web which I will show a little bit later
in my demo for you all right so we've
gotten the the four main pillars in the
outside right containers storage the
classifier the messaging component what
about the orchestration right how do we
actually make this thing run together
and turns out it's a handful of
components not just one but the core of
it is some kind of a an application
platform right whether that's cloud
functions app engine kubernetes Engine
or compute engine right you've got four
main options here that we need to run
some kind of a compute mechanism or some
sort of set of applications and services
to actually shuttle this stuff all the
way through once those images land in
storage they've got to get to the
classifier once they get to a classifier
we've got to parse those results back
out and decide if we want a message and
then keep that whole machine running so
I won't go into too much depth here
there have been a number of sessions
over the yesterday and probably some
more today and tomorrow around the
different compute platforms but at an
incredibly high level cloud functions
gives you the ability to run serve
Rollers functions right just like you'd
expect and those can be either a node or
Python App Engine lets you build more
full-blown apps or in services
let's us help you scale them
automatically based on incoming traffic
kubernetes engine is a level deeper than
app engine where you have the ability to
basically run containers and manage them
at scale across a larger number of
machines this is where the applications
might get more complicated they may have
more features and functionality and then
finally we give you really fast VMs in
compute engine so you have a few
different options here and I'll tell you
I think depending on the use case one or
one or another might make the most sense
I'm happy to talk to you know talk
through with with you know anyone of you
about which one's the right choice but
for most production applications most
production deployments we often see App
Engine or kubernetes engine because they
have a fair amount of capability and a
lot of knobs that you can still turn to
make things work the way you want them
to without giving you too much on the
compute engine side maybe not being too
limiting like you might run into you
with cloud functions all right so let's
put this all together and see what it
looks like so the biggest thing I would
say for again typical kind of production
use case is with Auto ml vision right a
train model a train model based on your
images and your image data and then
either App Engine or kubernetes engine
and using firebase right so those are
the really the four ten pill components
that we need to we need to use so if we
dig into an actual kind of rough
production architecture that I would
typically kind of suggest you would use
in this case what we have and the you
know about a hundred feet up for me on
the left there capture and upload all
right so that's capturing those images
capturing that video in a store
environment that little control plane I
talked about earlier that local device
that's gonna pull those images off and
actually package them up and send them
to the cloud that's that a little upload
device there and then it lands inside of
GCP and once it gets a GCP we've got a
handful of boxes and components here to
really drive this and make it happen so
the first thing we do is those images
land inside of Google Cloud storage and
cloud storage actually has this really
awesome feature called bucket change
notifications and what that means is
every time you
an object or you delete an object or you
change metadata an object it can
actually generate notifications for you
or generate messages for you and those
messages can go to a number of
downstream targets the two most popular
either cloud pub/sub our messaging
infrastructure or cloud functions in
this case I chose cloud pops up and I'll
get I'll come back to the why I made
that choice but what I've done here is
every time a new image is uploaded into
this bucket fires off a bucket change
notification that bucket change
notification that payload is actually
packaged up as a cloud pub/sub message
and sent to a topic that cloud pub/sub
topic has a push subscription on it and
that push subscription actually can send
it right to a target immediately in real
time so in this case what I've done is
I'm showing it going to a kubernetes
engine app right just a service that I'm
running in there called let's say a
process image that process image service
is actually gonna make the call to the
auto ml vision service it's gonna pass
the image along actually what it's gonna
do is not pass the actual physical image
it's gonna pass a cloud storage bucket
location of the image so I can just say
here's an image that's in cloud storage
please analyze it for me and it's gonna
give me back a JSON response run through
that JSON response look for what I need
to write any kind of restock message
that I want to have in there and then if
we need to restock something that
process image service will send another
message back out to a different pub sub
topic which has a push subscription to
another service inside of kubernetes
engine and that will decide to actually
make the connection to firebase and say
go ahead and send a push message to
whatever devices are appropriate to get
the message all right so it's a little
bit of a back-and-forth here but I did
this for a couple reasons
right you could actually orchestrate
this with probably a couple of cloud
functions and a little bit smaller scope
but again go back to the original
example right pretty big store with lots
of cameras a lot of stores so there's
gonna be a lot of data generated off of
those images right a lot of images
getting uploaded a lot of potential data
getting getting analyzed there so I
picked pub/sub for a particular reason
which is if you want to have the ability
to fan out and say well I want to I want
to analyze a lot of these events or I
want to persist each of these incoming
events as maybe time series for later
analysis or I want to drive a bunch of
other maybe downstream workflows based
on images being uploaded or based on
messages being sent right before they
get sent out you have the ability to do
cloud pub/sub right a single topic in
pub/sub can actually have multiple
subscriptions push or pull so that means
I could have different applications that
are gonna take action on the message or
I could have different have different
applications like a dataflow pipeline
that's analyzing the data coming out of
that pub/sub topic so it gives you a lot
of power and flexibility to change
components and swap them in and out or
add more or less so pop sum is a really
really powerful tool and I don't think
it gets nearly enough loved I think we
should we should talk about a lot more
in fact because it's it's incredibly
capable right it's this really really
powerful glue and you can add lots of
subscribers on to it with literally no
impact on performance no change for the
most part so this is a good example of
like a production approach that we might
take well as part of this I wanted to
show you guys a little bit demo so I
want to show you how to put this
together in kind of an example setup so
the first thing I needed right if we go
back to that bananas challenge was I
needed some sample data to test against
somebody sent me this photo they took a
long time ago this is Amina banana this
is actually not useful sample data for
for the test we're trying to do here so
not quite where we're looking for so
actually this is the these are the set
of images I used as kind of a basis here
so I went to a Google micro kitchen and
I took the bowl bananas out took it back
to my desk after I got some weird looks
from a few folks and I wrote this little
note in there that said restock the
bananas and I left it on the bottom and
you could see it's a poking out a little
bit in the middle image there and I took
these images with my phone so it's not a
completely accurate representation
because I've got a pretty good camera in
my phone so I actually scaled them down
to two megapixels and turn them black
and white and that's actually a pretty
close representation of what you get out
of a common camera color black and white
I think that's just a minor cost piece
but two megapixels was sort of the
a good average at a at a low price point
so I started with this and what I did
was I tried to build as much of the
production approach that I could so with
that let me switch to my laptop here and
show you guys perfect does that look
readable to everybody
thumbs okay I think we're okay we'll go
with it all right so in this directory
here and I've got cloud shell up and
running so this is inside my project so
what I've got are I've got nine images
the the bottom three are the original
one two and three so that was the first
second and third right the third has the
note in it and then I scale it down to
two megapixels and then I did black and
white and now if I have already the the
bucket setup and the pub subtopics set
up so if I can show you so I'm going to
show you that the bucket itself is
actually empty right now all right so
we'll see the buckets empty so the first
thing I'm going to do is copy in one of
the the out of stock images so that's
but thank you
never type in front of our crowd oops
alright so what I'm basically simulating
here is that local device taking an
image and pushing it up to a cloud
storage so I'm going to copy that image
in there and this is one of those out of
stock ones so what we should see in
about a second all right can you see
that a little notification down there at
the bottom it says inventory update time
to restock the bananas so in that time
what's happened is I uploaded the image
to a cloud storage fired off a bucket
change notification to pub/sub that
pub/sub topic delivered a message via
push subscription to an app engine app
in this case for demo purposes that app
engine app actually took the looked at
the payload of that message and said
okay a new image has been uploaded I'm
gonna go ahead and throw that image to
the stock vision API vision API came
back with the response and said yep I
see text another it says restock bananas
so I fired off another message from that
app engine app two pops up and said go
ahead and restock another app engine up
took over there and actually made the
connection of firebase and sent it off
so all that kind of happened in about a
second it takes about I think about a
second for our the first service and
then about a handful of millisecond less
than a second for the second part so
first thing I want to show you is what
that app engine service looks like for
the first part so the process image
component
so that's a little bit legible so
there's a little bit of boilerplate up
here at the top but I want to show that
you know the purpose here is not to kind
of go through a line by line read of
this code but really to tell you it's
not terribly complicated I spent more
time putting I think comments and and
some log statements and but really what
I'm doing is the first thing when you
set up that push subscription inside a
pub/sub you actually give it an end
point you say send the messages to the
send point so your end point actually
doesn't have to do anything with the
pub/sub mechanism it doesn't have to go
pull from it or actually authenticates
that service it just gets that as post
payload right right in right inside that
that request function and so now I get
it inside the request data and I can
actually turn that payload right I can
decode it and I can actually turn it
into a set of JSON and get the message
the message payload back out of it and
once I do that all I'm checking for to
make sure is is it actually you know is
this message coming from Google Cloud
Storage right just in case someone was
able to get access just want to have a
quick little debug check in there but
then I get down into what am I actually
doing all right so the first thing I'm
doing is I'm extracting the image path
the full path of that image that was
just uploaded and then I'm actually
creating a really quick call to the
vision API and it's only a handful of
lines you'll see it starts right down
here right first thing I do I create a
little client to talk to the vision API
and then I tell it I want to annotate an
image I give it the source location in
Google Cloud storage and then I ask you
to do two things gave me all the labels
right so detect all the outages objects
in the image and give me some labels and
some confidence around those and then
let me know if there's any text in the
image so when I get that payload back
what I'm able to do way down here is
actually iterate through all of the
label annotations and all the text
annotations that the vision API gave
back to me and figure out did it find
anything around restock bananas and so
once I find that yes it did indeed find
that find that text in the image then I
can send a message to cloud pub/sub and
let the downstream services they need to
take action let them know that we've got
a got a restock
and one interesting note here is if you
set up a cloud pub/sub push subscription
to an application you're actually not
going to return 200 okay you actually
need to return 204 which is an
interesting little tidbit but the
purpose root layer really is to make
sure that if you return 200 ok it's
actually not going to acknowledge the
message and it'll leave it in the queue
so you want to make sure that yes you
process the message you're gonna take
action and I'm gonna go ahead and
acknowledge and make sure that message
is no longer in the pub sub Q so that's
that service and now if we look at the
messaging service it's actually even
simpler so same sort of boilerplate at
the top here but a couple things to be
to note here is the first thing is I'm
gonna need access to the firebase
back-end admin controls because I'm
gonna use that to send the actual
downstream message I'm going to do in
the process message component really is
just again it's a push subscription so I
just need to unpack the payload unpack
that envelope and pull out the the data
that's in there make sure it says you
know restock bananas and then go ahead
and send a message to the firebase
messaging component and it's actually
going to figure out where to send it to
and so that's setup of where to send it
to you in this example what I did is I
built a simple little firebase web app
called proactively stocking inventory
and that first little bit at the top is
the instance ID that's the specific ID
of this browser so that it knows to send
push notifications to and so the way I
got this up there what you probably do
in a sort of a production scenario is
you know store this token inside of a
database or some other component what I
did here was I just actually put it as
part of the compute engine project
metadata so I was able to pull that pull
that token out and say send it to any of
the downstream targets that are in this
metadata key so I cheated a little bit
for the purpose of the demo but
ultimately it was able to figure out I
need to send it to this device and
that's where the notification came from
now what you're probably wondering is
does this really work right did I just
mock it up just so it does it
always restocked bananas and the answer
is no it actually does work as you'd
expect so if I take another image and
send it up there so bananas one is
actually the first image with the full
bowl so I'm gonna copy that into the
bucket so we'll watch that go through
all right so it's gonna copy that image
up there and I can show you the logs of
your bets I'm very exciting but
effectively what's happening here is
it's making its way through that
architecture through that process and
it's finding that nope there's no note
there's no text that says restock
bananas in there so I don't need to send
any notifications so now if we switch
back to the slides I can talk you
through a little bit of the architecture
I chose for the demo purposes so for
this one it actually looks relatively
similar to the production version right
I made a couple of little tweaks
primarily the use of App Engine
instead of kubernetes engine and I also
chose to use the stock vision API
instead of a trained custom model and
mostly because three images is not
enough to train a complex custom model
there but but ultimately right I took
those pictures with my phone I hand
uploaded it myself to a Google Cloud
storage and the notification it fired
back through came back through my web
browser in Chrome but the ends the you
know so the beginning and the end of
that are really specific to the demo
here but if you go back to the original
remember it's camera local device to do
the upload and that's actually a phone
or a handheld device on the other end
from firebase and so really there would
be note we could have to do with most
the architecture because everything on
the cloud side is actually pretty well
set up like you would normally want it
to work it's just a matter of changing
the upload the input segment and which
device are actually targeting and those
firebase messages actually have the
ability to be targeted across multiple
devices not just a single so you're not
sending a push notification to every
single team member you may have all of
your folks running with a you know a
custom-built app there and you may say
well I just want to send it to the Pete
who are subscribed to inventory updates
so now you have the ability actually
specifically target those that are ready
to run back to the room and restock
bananas and fill them in alright so
where do you go from here
so streaming and I mentioned this a
little bit up front but I think it's
worth revisiting
I think streaming is an interesting
approach right taking instead of
sampling taking that raw footage and
just throwing it up to the cloud and
maybe using instead of vision API using
the video intelligence API right the aps
are actually relatively similar in that
you know the video intelligence API
functions much like the vision API does
except it's looking at moving images
instead of you know or looking at a
frame by frame within a large set of
images as opposed to a single image but
it effectively functions the same way in
terms of the label objects face
detection that sort of thing but your
back to you right is it worth the
investment to stream that data do you
need to have the network bandwidth you
need to have a more capable device on
primer in the store to actually send
that data up it might not be right
depending on the the size and the scope
of the Diploma you're trying to put
together it might not be appropriate fit
well what about shelf based inventory
right how do we see all the way through
the back of a shelf we could with shelf
mounted cameras and it's actually a
great partner of ours tracks who's over
in the retail showcased in Moscone West
actually has shelf based cameras exactly
for this purpose so they've actually got
a really cool demo of stacks of a box of
stacks of boxes of donuts and every time
you pull a doughnut out it updates the
inventory count so that actually could
work for certain other use cases where
again there's sort of narrowly kind of
packed in items you can't get overhead
cameras and appropriately they've got a
good little shelf based system and it
functions in a lot of similar ways to
what I've shown you today what about a
custom model what if you want to go with
something that we can't do with vision
API or auto ml what if you need
something incredibly more specific well
that's where you can use something like
tensorflow
to build a very specific custom object
detection model and you actually run
that on top of our cloud ml engine
service and so what the cloud management
service gives you
is the ability to train an incredible
scale and do things like hyper parameter
tuning which lets you specify which
parameters in your model do you want to
tweak and how many permutations do you
want us to run them through so we can
actually take your model and say well
let's run you know 500 permutations
tweaking each of those individual
parameters and figure out which mix is
the right mix of parameters for your
model to be most effective and that's
like she baked into the service and then
when it's done training you can actually
promote that model to production and we
give you a nice little production and
prediction endpoint that we run a scale
for you as needed and that prediction
endpoint can be integrated into any
application so that's one option and
then if you need to get that machine
learning work really close to the edge
for whatever reason maybe you've got a
very custom use case maybe you want to
layer in some very specific detection
and the latency to cloud is just a
little bit too high right that could be
I could
that certainly could happen well running
machine learning models at the edge
running tensorflow models are hosted
tensorflow
not the I would say it's not a
non-trivial operation it does require a
fair amount of work so we have a package
actually called coop flow which takes
all the components you need to run which
you can learning models and host them
and actually even update them there and
run it on top of any kubernetes cluster
so you can imagine if you've got
infrastructure inside the store and
you've got you can deploy kubernetes on
there you can actually take those
terrain models and just push them down
to the store and run them in that
environment inside a coop flow and it
includes like notebook infrastructure
tensor board and a bunch of other tools
so that you can update those models
in-flight if you need to and the last
point which is not on here because it
does come up right I'm gonna go back a
handful of images cuz I want to show you
is this approach that I showed today is
actually based on stock being there less
and then gone but there's still some
amount of time it would take for that
notification to make it through even if
it's a couple of seconds it's still time
for someone to have to go get the
notification look at their phone
acknowledge it go back to the backroom
fill up a cart and then restock the
actual inventory so this might not
actually work for a lot of you right
that's where again something like auto
ml can really make the difference
because you may supply images like this
and say well for that middle one we're
gonna label images like that as low
stock and maybe you want the
notifications being generated by a low
stock not no stock so that kind of
distinction is really only possible
something auto ml right where we need to
get a little bit more fine-grain than
just general detection you want to add a
little bit more context to what you're
seeing and that's where something like
auto ml can make a difference so that
specific kind of training approach so
where do you go from here what's the
first thing you should do I urge all of
you if you have not had a chance to play
with vision API to go to cloud
google.com slash vision and start
uploading images right there's a nice
little box on there and that page where
you can just drag and drop nice little
html5 uploader drag and drop an image on
there and see all of the data that comes
back out it's incredible right it's you
can see every single thing and even if
you remember back to those images of the
banana and the bowl when I did those
results and I probably should have
pasted him in here what's really cool is
it told me you know it had wood in there
and it had a reasonably high confidence
that there was wood in the picture as
well as the bananas in there it actually
was able to read the stickers and tell
me what was on the sticker and it gave
me not only the amount that it saw of
the colors in both those in both those
things that those objects I've found it
also gave me the confidence that it had
that it were the actual individual
objects so it gets really really
specific and it's a really powerful tool
right and it's actually capable of doing
things like specific brand detection as
well if you take a picture of like the
Starbucks logo and you upload it it'll
actually tell you without even seeing
the words but it's the Starbucks logo or
you know the Nike swoosh on the side of
a shoe so it's a pretty incredible
capable API because it's been trained
across the library of images that Google
has access to right so that's the thing
I would start with right go through that
upload an image look through all the
results look through what you can find
and throw kind of crazy things at it
right because it's a lot of fun to see
what you might be able to build what you
be able to do with the data that comes
out of those images there's so much
hidden in there then I think we might
take for granted the second game I would
do I would have you do
coming out of this session is check out
some of these other ones that are coming
up today and tomorrow so injecting AI
into your applications then gets more
specific around each of the trained
pre-trained machine learning api is that
we have as part of GCP the vision
session actually goes into specifically
the stock vision API as well as the
power that called a cloud auto ml gives
it and where you can supercharge it then
there's also intelligent image analytics
infrastructure and that goes again a
level deeper into more and more of those
use cases and then the last one is
hybrid machine learning that actually
talks a lot about coop flow and running
kind of in kubernetes environments
whether at the edge or in your own data
center but it goes into what does that
machine learning lifecycle look like
right what if you wanted to train on the
cloud and then take that train model and
run it at the edge or run it in your
data center all right so we give you
those capabilities so those are some of
the sessions I would strongly urge you
to check out and the last thing I would
say is if you've got questions I'm happy
to take some questions here we've got a
little bit extra extra time there are
two mics at the end or you can yell it
out and I will try to repeat it best I
can and then the second request I have
for you is by all means take the survey
let me know what you liked weeds and
liked about this session because I'm
happy to do better next time thank you
you
[Music]